Batman V Superman's theatrical release was
2 and a half hours long, but we'll be getting
an extended R-rated cut with the Blu-ray and
DVD release which Zack Snyder has dubbed the
Ultimate Cut.
So, what didn't make it into the final movie
and what other unused concepts may we see
in future movies?
Just before kicking off, I've got a fantastic
giveaway from our friends at Titan Books for
the official tech manual for Batman V Superman:
Dawn of Justice.
Inside this fab hardback book are tons of
amazing concept art, an exclusive look at
Batman's arsenal, vehicles, Batsuits, and
Batcave, as well as Superman's Kryptonian
suit and Wonder Woman's iconic weaponry.
For a chance to win, subscribe and leave a
comment about the deleted scenes or what you'd
like to see in the extended cut of Batman
V Superman.
For more details and ways to enter, check
out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
OK, quick spoiler warning, obviously if you
haven't seen Batman V Superman yet, I'll be
discussing a ton of spoilers so come back
as soon as you've had a chance to see the
movie.
First up, there was a much longer opening
sequence filmed with Lois Lane in the African
village Nairomi that will be included in the
extended cut.
In the longer scene, the unnamed undercover
CIA op who was with Lois, reveals himself
as Daily Planet photographer Jimmy Olsen and
tells Lois he's been assigned to her for the
mission.
Director Zack Snyder had originally hoped
to cast Jesse Eisenberg as Jimmy Olsen which
he felt would create a real WTF moment when
the character was killed right at the beginning
of the movie, especially because Eisenberg
is a well-known actor.
Snyder has defended his decision to kill off
the beloved DC character saying that there
wasn't "room for Jimmy Olsen" in the current
DC movie universe that Warner Bros is building.
Jena Malone filmed some scenes that we can
definitely look forward to in the Ultimate
Cut.
Her role is still unconfirmed, although Zack
Snyder has said she isn't Robin or Batgirl.
Based on what we know so far, Malone is likely
playing Oracle, a computer hacker in the comics
who provides tech support to a range of superheroes.
In The Killing Joke graphic novel, the Joker
shot Barbara Gordon, paralysing her, which
led her to become Oracle.
Another hint towards this theory is that in
DC's TV universe, when Green Arrow was wondering
what codename to give Felicity Smoak, he said
that Oracle was already taken.
Although the TV and film universes are separate,
it could be a cheeky little hint that we'll
be seeing Oracle on the big screen.
A scene was filmed in 2013 at East LA College
for a football game at Gotham City University
stadium between the home team and Metropolis
State University.
It seems that this scene could be an introduction
to Vic Stone, aka Cyborg, who is a football
player in the comics.
It's possible that some kind of tragedy or
terrible injury happened to Vic at the football
game which is why we see him with missing
arms and legs later just before he's turned
into Cyborg by the motherbox at Star Labs.
"Ahman Green, the [former] running back from
the Green Bay Packers" is credited in the
film as Thug #2 and he's confirmed to be in
the extended cut and may have something to
do with this scene.
The supervillain Metallo was originally going
to be the key villain in the Man of Steel
sequel.
In the comics, Metallo is a cyborg who uses
kryptonite as his power source and was created
by the scientist Emmet Vale who, like Lex
Luthor in Batman V Superman, was concerned
about Superman's power.
But when they decided to make Batman V Superman
rather, than a standalone Superman sequel,
the idea of having Metallo as the villain
was put on ice.
However, Metallo's creator Emmet Vale, played
by actor Ralph Lister, did appear in the movie
working at the Lexcorp lab, leaving the path
open for the villain to appear in a future
film.
Zack Snyder has said that Batman villains
the Joker and Riddler were almost put in Batman
V Superman.
However, Snyder and screenwriter Chris Terrio
later felt their addition would be a distraction
from the main protagonists Batman and Superman.
But the supervillains' presence is still felt
in a number of easter eggs that made their
way into the movie such as the Riddler and
Joker graffiti that litters the run-down building
where Batman and Superman fight and the Joker
graffiti all over the defaced Robin suit.
On the subject of dead Robin, his weapon,
which you see together with his suit in the
Batcave, was originally built as a fully intact
piece.
Later, Snyder decided that the weapon needed
to be shown broken as a further hint at what
happened to Robin at the hands of the Joker.
By the way, the Batwing was also designed
with a second seat which is where Robin would
have sat before he was killed ten years before
the events of Batman V Superman.
Since that happened, Bruce Wayne has modified
the empty space to use it as convenient storage
for an extra set of guns.
The Batwing was designed to have folding wings
so that when it's in the Batcave and covered
with a tarp it looks and hangs just like a
bat.
The Batwing did of course appear in the theatrical
release, but we didn't get to see the folding
wings.
Also, production designer Patrick Tatopoulos
said it was crucial that Batman had the ability
to take off and land anywhere, even an alley.
So, the designers also made sure the Batwing
had the ability to take off vertically and
they even ran a CG test to prove the Batwing
could do just that, even though this didn't
happen in the final film.
Henry Cavill was spotted filming scenes outside
the Gotham City jail and producer Deborah
Snyder has confirmed that scenes where Clark
Kent visits Gotham to look into Batman's activities
more closely will appear in the extended cut.
Bodybuilder CT Fletcher has confirmed he was
on set for a prison scene, so it looks like
we'll get to see more details about Clark
Kent's investigation into some of the Bat
vigilante's victims.
Dan Amboyer, who starred in the TV comedy
Younger, has said he was on the set of Batman
V Superman "right at the beginning of shooting"
and that he played a character called Lieutenant
Christie.
On IMDB he's credited as "Drone Pilot" and
it's been rumoured he could end up as one
of the Green Lanterns.
It remains to be seen whether what he filmed
makes it into the extended cut and whether
we'll get a tease for Green Lantern in Batman
V Superman or if we'll have to wait for the
first Justice League movie.
Just after the opening weekend for Batman
V Superman, Warner Bros released an intriguing
deleted scene titled "Communion".
In it we see a SWAT team descend into the
Kryptonian scout ship, The Fortress of Solitude,
where they find Lex Luthor communing with
a demonic-looking creature.
The creature feels like it might hail from
Darkseid's planet Apokolips, and its look
best matches Darkseid's father Yuga Khan.
Other alternatives could be Steppenwolf, one
of Darkseid's generals or even possibly the
DCEU's version of Darkseid himself.
Darkseid was already teased in the main theatrical
release via the Omega symbol that Bruce Wayne
sees in his Knightmare.
In this deleted scene, there are also 3 motherboxes
and an orb floating above the demonic creature
and they all dissolve away as the soldiers
reach Lex.
It looks like Lex is learning about Darkseid
and his forces via holographic images.
The moment calls back to when Clark Kent returned
to the scout ship in Man of Steel and learned
about Krypton and the universe from his father
Jor-El.
The deleted scene helps to tie up the easter
eggs from the theatrical release, like Lex
Luthor's mention of gods falling from the
sky when talking about the painting in his
study, and the "ding, ding, ding" he says
at the end of the film which references the
ping sound that motherboxes make in the comics.
So guys, what do you think about the deleted
scenes?
Do you think they would have made the movie
better or would they have made it more complicated?
As always, I'd love to hear what you've got
to say in the comments below.
Don't forget to comment and subscribe for
your chance to win this awesome official hardback
book, the tech manual for Batman V Superman:
Dawn of Justice!
For more details and ways to enter, check
out the Gleam link in the video description
below!
If you enjoyed this video, you might like
to explore the movie further with my guide
to all the easter eggs and references in the
movie, and very shortly I'll have a video
up with cool facts about the making of Batman
V Superman and also a special Wonder Woman
video!
You can click on any of the links right here
to check those out.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!